researchers from Georgia Tech are
developing warm skin for robots the
active thermal sensing combines with
traditional force sensing to allow the
robot to touch identify wood and
aluminum with 96% accuracy and the acorn
worm one of our closest invertebrate
relatives can regrow every major body
part including its nervous system
internal organs and its head and humans
may share all of the genes that they use
to do this base sauce Kevin here this is
my flow
[Music]
digital capture of eyeballs is now a
whole lot easier
Disney Research Zurich has developed a
parametric model that allows quicker
less intrusive reconstruction of eyes
using a database of pre captured eyes a
single photo from the internet is all
that's needed to create the digital eyes
and the system also includes artistic
control over parameters like vein depth
and thickness iris geometry and pupil
dilation the fitting technique algorithm
works so well it can even recreate
digital versions of eyeballs from
paintings so yeah
spider ward grew an ear on an apple the
company is developing an open-source co2
incubator as well as cellulose
biomaterials to grow cells in your house
basically scaffolds for growing cells
typically come from animal or human
tissue but they're developing cell wall
architectures from the plants and fungus
kingdoms the system is in the presale
stage right now and the hope is to allow
low-cost and open-source DIY kits for
schools labs and garages scientists at
Harvard have invented a cigarette
smoking robot the machine lights and
then essentially inhales and exhales the
smoke from up to 10 cigarettes at a time
a tiny chip inside covered with living
cells from human lungs is then used to
analyze the effects they also have a 3d
printed heart on a chip device and the
plan is to eventually create an entire
human on a chip to link ten organ chips
together and study the entire human body
living organisms have been persuaded to
make chemical bonds not found in nature
researchers at Caltech are breeding
molecules with silicon carbon compounds
something only chemists could previously
accomplish synthetically created
organosilicon compounds are currently
used in pharmaceuticals semiconductors
and also computer and TV screens and
this new bonding method called directed
evolution is non-toxic cheaper more
efficient and easier to modify than
chemical synthesis and this is more
about reducing the need for precious
metals and making silicon carbon bonds
than it is about creating Andrew
for now two paralyzed monkeys can walk
again thanks to a brain spine interface
neuro engineers at Brown University
recorded the electrical signals from the
movement controlling area of the
monkey's brain then decoded and sent
them to implanted electrodes on the
spine the signal stimulated the spinal
cord and the monkeys not only walked but
reacted naturally to the regained motion
and they're working on improving the
hardware with the hope they can someday
be used to aid paraplegic humans suit X
is augmenting the power of human bodies
the flexible exoskeletons are designed
to reduce injury and bolster
productivity by providing assistance
lifting squatting and bending three
models back x shoulder x and leg x can
reduce muscle force up to 50 percent
they're currently aimed at helping
construction and factory workers but
they also have the Phoenix which is the
world's lightest exoskeleton to help
those with mobility disorders a new
magnetic ink prints self-healing devices
micro particles organized by a magnetic
field become attracted to one another in
the event of a tear allowing the device
to heal itself the repair can occur with
a tear up to three millimeters which is
a record in self-healing systems and the
magnetic ink could be used to create
self-healing batteries and wearable
electrical circuits finally researchers
from Northwestern University have
developed a wearable skin sensor to
measure the composition of your sweat so
it launches an app it provides that
voice recognition that there's a
connection here and then the phone takes
a picture of the device and from
analysis of the colors of these
different reservoirs that are filled
with these color responsive chemical
reagents we can determine quantitatively
the glucose level the pH the lactate
concentration of the chloride
concentration as well as the total sweat
loss during a given period
I'm gonna leave it with a non
anthropomorphic walking robot which
means it doesn't walk like this it walks
like you'll see and as always thanks for
watching in the operating room the first
light of its kind is installed no
portion of an operation is ever in
shadow nor is the expectant father
forgotten here he can get the news
officially and self around of the most
comfortable circumstances possible and
for mother well she is only to call for
her baby and baby come sliding through a
wall in a draw like bassinet for a
little visit with the new mother he and
his two million dollar institution doors
are opened by remote control and on the
single floor patients are easily moved
from place to place green grounds for a
dream Hospital
for exclusive Vsauce gear and a steady
flow of mind-blowing loot subscribe to
the curiosity box